[Musica]
vorrei che tutti voi ora pensate al
vostro più grande rimpianto
pensateci bene pensateci forte
esattamente che cos'è quel dettaglio di
questo ricordo che lo rende un rimpianto
è stato forse la paura di buttarsi o
magari qualche limite che ci siamo posti
per non soffrire per un eventuale
fallimento
magari un pregiudizio
ora pensate al vostro più grande sogno
quello che vi fa alzare la mattina
non so potrebbe essere la vostra
carriera entrare nella top università
costruire la vostra famiglia
che cos'è che oggi vi impedisce di
ottenerlo
ancora una volta è la paura di buttarsi
o un limite che ci siamo posti per non
soffrire per un eventuale fallimento
un pregiudizio
qualche anno ma ho deciso di non volermi
più nutrire dei miei limiti
ho deciso di ottenere quello che volevo
questo sono io è un momento molto
delicato al momento prima della partenza
la tensione alle stelle c'è tutta una
procedura bisogna controllare gli sci
gli alettoni il paraschiena il casco per
chi non conoscesse questo sport il
chilometro lanciato ci si veste come un
preservativo rosso e ci si lancia giù da
una montagna con gli sci e un casco
aerodinamico
il gioco è chi va più veloce vince
questo sono io che voglio rompere i miei
limiti uscire dalla mia zona di comfort
anche questo sono io nel 2017 sono
arrivata seconda nella mia categoria nel
mondo women speed down hill
quello che non si vede in questa foto
sono
le paure gli infiniti allenamenti
l'estate passate a 2 gradi in cima a una
montagna
le notti insonni gli scoraggiamenti le
cadute fallimenti tutti i piccoli passi
chi mi hanno portato fino a questo mio
piccolo se vogliamo un successo
non si vede il momento in cui ho deciso
che sarei salita su quel podio che
avrei superato quel limite
ad oggi al mondo ci sono
la condizione della donna ci sono dei
paesi dove la condizione della donna è
molto ristretta per valori culturali
sociali religiosi
in alcuni paesi le donne non possono
studiare non possono vestirsi come
vogliono non possono dire quello che
pensano
io stessa quando ho vissuto in egitto e
in argentina non sempre avevo la
possibilità di fare quello che volevo
noi viviamo nella parte fortunata del
mondo quella dove le donne possono
potenzialmente fare tutto ciò che
vogliono
eppure per me è sempre stato molto
difficile trovare
modelli non modelle
figure femminili alle quali ispirarmi
per sognare di diventare come loro
la donna invisibile ci chiama così
carolina creato per es quando racconta
di come la nostra società sia
basata disegnata su standard maschili
dalla politica del governo
i media la tecnologia la ricerca medica
i luoghi di lavoro la pianificazione
urbana
la donna invisibile
io ho studiato il liceo classico qui a
milano e al liceo studiamo di uomini
fantastici eroici
scientifici famosi
sì ci sono le donne euripide medea fedra
alcesti che nel loro piccolo sradicano
questo ruolo tipico della donna e escono
da una posizione subordinata minoritaria
nel mito greco e nel medioevo nel
rinascimento nella filosofia la
letteratura nella storia le figure
femminili sono poche
spesso deboli
comunque questa è la nostra storia la
storia di una società patriarcale quindi
accettiamo
ma ci sono cose che non possiamo più
accettare
dopo il liceo mi sono trasferita in
svizzera dove ho fatto l'università
io ho studiato matematica e ero
circondata da matematici fisici
informatici uomini in italia di tutte le
donne che frequentano l'università
soltanto il 18 per cento sceglie delle
materie scientifiche
questo probabilmente dato dal fatto che
le ragazze hanno delle lacune in queste
materie che crescono a via via e che
sono generalmente dovute a stereotipi di
genere
mi chiedo in qualche modo allora non
siamo noi stesse che ci poniamo questi
limiti
da quattro anni lavoro nel mondo
dell'imprenditoria digitale
ho lavorato prima un anno in italia e
poi tre anni in africa ahonen off e la
rivoluzione digitale una rivoluzione
recente che come ci racconta baricco nel
suo libro the game è stata una
rivoluzione che è stata portata avanti
da una classe maschile bianca dove le
donne hanno un ruolo marginale se non
totalmente assente
questo è oggi
questo non è il medioevo
l'anno scorso nel 2020 nel mondo del
venture capital europeo che è
investimenti in start up le donne hanno
raccolto lo 0,7 per cento del capitale
totale
ancora una donna ancora una volta la
donna invisibile
allora se guardo alla mia vita questi
tre grandi blocchi il liceo l'università
il lavoro e trovo lo stesso scenario
inconsciamente forse accettiamo diciamo
noi non possiamo essere lì nei libri di
storia su quel podio
ma allora non è ancora di più una nostra
responsabilità
dimostrare a noi stessi che possiamo
essere i nostri modelli per noi e per
tutte le altre donne
nei momenti nella vita in cui mi sono
sentita un po bloccata ci sono stati dei
punti cardinali che mi hanno aiutato ad
andare avanti
e stasera li vorrei condividere con voi
il primo è
accessibilità
io sogno di un mondo dove le donne hanno
accesso a tutte le opportunità possono
fare quello che vogliono diventare chi
vogliono
citazione nella vita siamo spesso
giudicati per quello che facciamo quello
che diciamo che mangiamo come ci
vestiamo
io voglio restituire il diritto di
sperimentare quando qualcuno gioca a
calcio la tira e la sbaglia
capita
può capitare il diritto di fallire anzi
il dovere di fallire perché con il
fallimento che si impara che si va
avanti
celebrazione questo è qualcosa che ho
imparato facendo tanti arti marziali
qualcosa tipico della cultura orientale
che dovremmo copiare
non fa parte della nostra cultura che di
per se vuole sempre sempre sempre di più
funziona così una volta definito
l'obiettivo finale
spezzettarlo in tanti piccoli obiettivi
e quando si raggiunge ognuno di essi
festeggiare celebrare bravo brava ce
l'hai fatta
ora puoi andare oltre uscire da questa
tua piccola zona di comfort che ti sei
creato
guardare in faccia la paura
diventare una cosa sola con lei
azione
qui forse userei un inglesismo take
action
prende relazione gli viene in mente lode
di orazio carpe diem cogliere cogliere
l'opportunità
e infine insieme insieme perché da sola
io non ce l'avrei mai fatta salire su
quel podio
insieme perché ce l'ho fatta a tutte le
persone che mi hanno aiutato e
supportato
lo scorso febbraio ho invitato alcuni
amici a festeggiare il mio compleanno in
montagna e mi sono ritrovata sulle piste
da sci con i miei amici maschi le
ragazze erano rimaste a casa una doveva
guardare il bambino una doveva non so
aveva male alla schiena una aveva freddo
una scena che ho visto innumerevoli
volte quando sono una delle poche
affari tra le onde o in cima alle
montagne
questa volta però è successo qualcosa di
diverso qualcosa nella mia testa ha
fatto clic
mi sono detta ma è anche una mia
responsabilità perché io ogni giorno
assisto questa scena e non faccio nulla
per cambiare le cose
mi ha fatto molto riflettere questa cosa
e
dopo alcuni mesi ho deciso di lasciare
il lavoro e lanciare il mio progetto
gross went out
clause vantate una comunità di donne che
si supportano l'un l'altra per uscire
dalla zona di confort e ottenere quella
che noi chiamiamo la realizzazione di sé
la libertà la libertà dai nostri stessi
limiti dalle nostre stesse paure
ho deciso di fondare questo progetto
sulle cose che mi stanno particolarmente
a cuore ovvero lo sport nella natura e
crescerà su questi sei pilastri
è una two responsabilità se ogni giorno
decidi o no di inseguire i tuoi sogni
è una tua responsabilità di abbandonare
i tuoi limiti per la magia e se lo
facciamo insieme
questo induce ad un cambiamento sociale
crea un'immagine globale che è
differente e che quindi determina un
progresso
per ottenere i nostri sogni
oltre i limiti grazie